right why people be doing crazy [__]
dude I just saw a video on Twitter shout
outs to Twitter once again yeah of this
girl she's like known to swim with tiger
sharks like specifically a tiger shark
that she's developed a relationship with
over the years right and she's about to
dive in right and she dips her head in
to see the water and then when she pulls
her head out [__] shark comes at the
bite her face oh my God she's like
i'm like [__] yeah you almost died
right now are you talking about people
in the comment section they're like well
as you can see the shark didn't bear its
teeth so it was just playing the [__] do
you know about a shark did you talk to
it yeah this [__] don't look like play
to me I didn't even know Sharks play bro
that's what I'm saying